that didn't take long
covet hypocrite nancy pelosi already
breaking her new mask rules
republicans slamming the speaker for
what they call a massive abuse of power
in the house
republican lawmakers protesting the new
rules after a capitol police memo
said staffers and visitors could be
arrested
for not covering their faces and police
are backing
away from that order but lawmakers could
still face hefty fines
and they aren't happy we will not comply
you know nancy pelosi has opted to
rule as speaker of the house more as a
tyrant
than a speaker of the people's house
nancy pelosi is totally off the rails
she has gone totally nuts on this thing
that's what the american people don't
want to see anymore
is this kind of tyrannical behavior by
the people who are running our
institutions
that comes as the cdc finally releases
the data
justifying its 180 on masks documents
say the delta variant can spread as
easily as the chickenpox
and vaccinated people can become
infected and may be able to spread it
but the cdc also says breakthrough cases
are still uncommon
and the data is preliminary thanks
and as the new york post points out out
of 161 million vacced
5601 caught breakthrough coveted and
were hospitalized
and just 1141 died or .007
all right greg you have more
likelihood of dying in a car crash
than you do of dying from covet if
you're vaccinated so i don't think
anybody should drive anymore
yeah i don't even think it's close on
that but what gets me mad is that you
can be arrested they were saying you
could be arrested for not wearing a mask
meanwhile you could shoplift 900 worth
of stuff from california
over and over in california at any place
and not be arrested
uh you can mug and assault people in new
york city you'll be out before the
paperwork is done
but you can go to jail if you're not
wearing a mask in dc
what do you tell your cell mate it's not
very impressive when you're put in the
house what are you in here for you're
interested i didn't wear a mess and the
worst thing is the wri when this
story was originally came out the
staffers could be arrested
but not the actual house members so
think about that is pure political
privilege you want to you want an
example of systemic
inequality that's it i mean imagine
you're walking with your boss
and neither of you are wearing masks and
then and and you're not gonna wear them
and the officer says well i gotta take
you but you can stay
i actually like that of course because
you would throw your staff
under the bus at any moment but we know
we know that this inequality exists in
politics
it's in fact it's the most compelling
reason to become a politician is to
become exempt
from the rules that you yourself create
and so that's why gavin newsom got gets
the party without his mask and hunter
biden gets to violate gun
laws and politicians can fix secret
problems you can drive off a bridge with
a woman and she could die
and you can still have a political
career that's why they're in politics to
get away with
murder figuratively and literally
richard
your thoughts well i agree with greg i
mean you could not release your tax
return to the people and still not go to
jail that's not the same thing
you knew that was coming though that's
too obvious of course so you knew it was
coming
uh i told you you said it was coming but
listen uh here's the thing i think we
have to figure out how we got here first
which is the larger question right
how did we get to the point where we're
back at mass and the reason why we're
back in mass is because we have a people
there's people in this country that
aren't vaccinated and unvaccinated
people are spreading
the delta variant it's not true we're
back
why are we back in mass then if it's not
because of the spread of covet 19
we are back we are back at the mass
because we don't have a plan
are we are we are you denying that
covert 19's not spreading in the current
moment no i'm not saying that
people are vaccinated should not be
wearing masks of course but how do you
verify someone's vaccinated by somebody
who's not very back
ask them and it's that's how this goes
but the problem here is you can't have
your cake needed to on this particular
case because you
take out of it richard fair you can't
have your apples and eat it too i don't
care what analogy you want to use here
but you can't say
we don't want to do masks we don't want
any lockdowns we're also not going to
take the vaccine you can't have all
three of those things at the same time
because if you do that
you have increase in hospitalizations
you have an increase in death which is
what's happening in parts of the country
right now when saying that i would love
to answer some of richard's questions
yeah please because i don't think
richard maxes up wherever he's supposed
to be no i
was just on a flight and i had my mask
i'm not talking about i'm talking about
on the ground
yeah go to the grocery store with my
mascot cause it's first of all do not
i've seen you out there the reason we
have live in dc how are you i've seen
you
i have people yeah i'm not sure because
spies everywhere uh well the first
first reason we have muhank ronavirus
and coven in the first place is because
of the chinese communist party
and because people like dr fauci trusted
the world world health organization
early on and therefore we never actually
found out
what really happened and therefore we
had a hard time combating this from
the very beginning in terms of why we
are wearing masks
now according to the cdc director she
says that
vaccinated people are now infecting
other vaccinated people so that is the
justification
as she said the main reason why they
issued these
additional mass mandates after reversing
them from their decision just two months
ago
i think we need to pump the brakes on
the panic here if you look at the data
of who
is susceptible to death or
hospitalization even without the vaccine
if you are
from ages 18 to 64 you have a 99.5
of surviving coveted 19 without a
vaccine
that's from the cdc those are the
numbers if you are over 65
your your risk goes up for death or
hospitalization
in terms of the new variant for delta
the media is panicking and recklessly
reporting it as
there are more cases more
hospitalizations the hospitalized are
unvaccinated
and the the breakthrough cases are not
serious illness so this the standard has
moved to
cases are people just getting sick
rather than having a very serious
illness and they're creating panic out
of it because it's good for the media
and the cdc has been terrible on the
messaging on this we've been talking
about it all week so
if you want to talk about why we're back
here it's because the standards have
moved
and they are treating people in a way
that doesn't allow them to have civil
liberties and not listening to their
concerns about why maybe people
won't get vaccinated and even that
washington post report that came out
last night that had those
internal cdc slide presentations and was
talking about the fact
that they are going to now have to move
the goal post in
full shannon we're just going to have to
cut you off because no one can hear you
apparently you're my should i come over
here
speaking to the mic shannon we're going
to give you this oh oh oh oh well
i like this this is so cozy uh anyway
listen the cdc is now going to have to
move the goal posts
in full view of the public as the
washington post said last night because
we're getting this more data
but again if the data is relying on a
study out of india partially
um that deals with vaccines that we
don't oh goodbye
i think i have my mic now um that deals
with vaccines that aren't
are you sure you want to know about this
this is weird
we're not social distance uh the cdc has
confused so many people that even when
you have
mainstream media saying it's so
confusing people don't want to go along
with it because it keeps changing all
the time
talking about the media they've had a
total meltdown in dc where many of us at
this table live
and work and eat and do all those kinds
of things saying you know the mayor says
tweeted this afternoon the city's open
but everybody's gonna have to remask and
there are businesses now complaining
saying we have held on for 15 16 months
this is so confusing people aren't going
to come out again because they're afraid
they think they can't get in without a
mask we don't know what to do and you're
hurting
our ability to try to reopen at this
point i mean i agree with that i
understand that the cdc's messaging has
been very confusing i will not deny that
i think it's
and i said this lesson on your show
shannon i think the messaging's been
very confusing but it doesn't take away
from the fact
that hospitalization rates are back to
where we were in january and
in well excuse me they're back to
mid-may and april according to bloomberg
right so
in places like florida mid-march and
early april that's still more people
than we were you're talking 2021
2020. over the last two weeks there are
about one person yeah but dc is
different
we're talking about different regions
they've averaged one death a week in dc
but that's a different but those are
different regions and i agree with you
well
during that same period in dc we've had
11 homicide victims
yeah more likely to get shot dead than
diakovic in dc richard
we're only thinking about dc we're not
talking about the other people we were
talking about dc
because that was the topic of the
segment hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else